it had me this way
oh
look that terminal should give us what
we need
[Music]
um
[Music]
interesting
good news first
we're close
there's a banished structure above us
it's big
oh
no
what is it
there's a message
you
i'm sorry
i couldn't
he's alive barely we need to help him
please
do i have your attention spartan
do i
you feel his pain
each twist of my blade hurts you as much
as him he will not die by my hand but he
will suffer
until you stand before me
for the banished
victory is our shared cry
refusal to cower
to bend our weaknesses beaten from us
banished
it makes us strong
oh
humanity makes you weak
vulnerable
defeatable
[Music]
our time together is ending
i await our final fight
chief
there are coordinates embedded in the
message
we're going to find him
the banished have found us
steve look out
oh
uh
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
wait that's there's something ahead out
the window
i recognize that structure in the
distance
not by sight but by signal
purpose
unknown but the banished are diverting
forces to guard its construction if it's
rebuilt i can only imagine their
intention
it won't be
is
me
see humans
hmm
oh
[Music]
station currently holds 76 spartan fours
they have orders to stand against you
short-sighted fools
you have served me well leonidas
your sacrifice
is appreciated
no
she took out the training facility
those spartans all gone
all of them
why would she
let's move
there's another lift nearby it'll take
us close to the surface
[Music]
and it's not powered up
the banister trying to trap us down here
we're going to need to find a way to get
it back online
soon
[Music]
i'll tear you apart
don't stop
oh
get it off
i have done it i am victorious
you can't fire
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
looks like we're trapped in here
or maybe
a not just powered up
forgive me
not enough power
wait
is that
earth
yes
what's it doing here
it's beautiful
we need more power
let's go
[Applause]
this kill is
mine uh
hmm
the world is too full
this is not a negotiation
this is your surrender
my turns are clear
you are aware of my capabilities
and i am fully acquainted with yours
if the earth's government wants to fight
feel free
wait she
she threatened earth
her forces led an assault on the unsc in
sydney
wiped it out
wiped out the headquarters
all of it we had to hide regroup
come up with a plan
to stop her
to survive
atriox
leader of the banished
how do you stand
with the banished
always
forever
and you understand the consequences of
defiance
i do
do
you the intricacies of any action are
complex
the reactions numerous yet mostly
predictable
look upon dorsek one last time
and remember
you chose this path
as did you
call donna
she destroyed their home
esherams
atrioxes
an entire planet
how could she do that
it's my fault
how
i should have stopped it
i could have reasoned with her
could you
it was her choice her
programming
was it
i don't know anymore
there's something you're not telling me
i'm
the only way to access the ring
to reach cortana
was to make a copy
i'll get this open
reconsider the consequences of your back
to your conservatory monitor
there's your grav lift
let's get this over with
and remember
you chose this path
i'm her
yes
an exact copy
it was the only option we had left
my
routines systems
all copies
halsey removed any information that
could compromise you
you're her
if we'd never met
will i do what she did
become what she became
am i that already
my mission was to ensure that doesn't
happen
it still is
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
that wasn't me
it can't be
i shouldn't be here
your mission
was to destroy me
i've restored the deletion protocols
i'm ready
it has been an honor
just promise me one thing
whatever happens
save him
he needs you you're all he has
we do it together
how
can you
trust me
i don't
but i want to
okay
let's go save him
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
of
of
course
we made it
now all we need to